but so in right in in terms of we're
talking about the potential for war for
war with china
we have the story from yahoo so much at
stake pm's chilling
warning on conflict with china as prime
minister scott morrison
will he will call on the world leaders
to stand in unison against the growing
threat
of china on wednesday he will deliver a
major foreign policy speech out of a
trip to the united kingdom
where he'll be a guest at a meeting of
the world economic powers including the
us germany and france
bro it sounds like war with china is
seriously on the horizon it's not just
this not just australia being like yo
it's it's happening i mean obviously
china came back and they're like ah
that's that's rubbish there's no war
the u.s just dispatched its pacific
fleet across the pacific
in anticipation of chinese rockets well
right but
so they initially so the u.s has has
their airfleet two different bases one
in japan i think in okinawa could be
wrong
and one in guam and there was concern
that you're talking about the
aircraft or the navy uh it's the air
force it's the air force
yeah so they were worried that these
chinese rockets would just wipe out
these bases instantly they have no time
no time to scramble it wouldn't just be
the the bases be the entire island i
mean i i've gone through those scenarios
when i was the navy and
i mean it basically comes down to like
at what time would they be destroying
what facility right
okinawa was right there so but but so
what the us has done is they've
dispatched the fleet
around the pacific so now there's like
some bombs here some planes there
and they straight up said oh it's so you
know and it is in anticipation of with
china
we will not be vulnerable to these
attacks we're seeing that we're all
seeing the pentagon
is buying up weapons specifically for
naval and pacific
pacific warfare as opposed to middle
eastern warfare like drone strikes and
things like that
seems like the city's trap is a is a
given and they recognize it
now maybe the economic stuff was an
attempt to stop it maybe
this like nba stuff was like the more
business we build up the less likely
there will be a war and war was bad
sounds like war is going to happen yeah
so i i'll put it this way that
if is there an earpier competitor that
would be at the most
and when i say that i mean another state
actor which would have a comparable
military to the united states
that the us could potentially go towards
number one definitely china 100
right the reason that i'm still would it
you know i'd bet against it it's like
i'd put it 60 40 right now
is is because they're just making so
much money off of us right they're
constantly making money off of us
they're
even more money now after the pandemic
which they certainly played to their own
you know i'm not one of those people who
thinks the pandemic was you know a
deliberate plot or anything like that by
them
but i think it's something that once
once it hit they realized how to spin
everything in their favor financially
speaking um they're positioning
themselves to be the
the major beneficiaries of the great
reset they're still in bed with all of
our elites with all the western elites
and
and by and large have been financed and
built up by western elites
so here's right they're essentially
winning so why would they you know why
why go why would go hot right why shoot
and the only thing that i think
that could potentially lead to that is
if you see
the actual party from the inside be
threatened if you see xi jinping feel
that his
rule is threatened if you see him
potentially weakened
and you know by rivals then maybe does
he make a play for taiwan maybe
there's a bunch of protests breaking out
across the country which could threaten
to destabilize the social order
that's why i keep an eye on it yeah well
so so you're mentioning this
a moment ago uh in in the in the earlier
segment but uh just a minute ago
that these massive protests were
breaking out in all across china
i mean is that something you think could
make the chinese communist party
fear their control over the country
potentially but that's going to lead to
internal crackdowns that wouldn't be
something that would
you know they would want to do some kind
of like um you know external big like
wag the dog type
approach to anything and you know xi
jinping is starting to now get
credit for essentially not you know i
wouldn't say the return of hong kong but
just the control of hong kong right they
they view this as a huge win and if you
look at those
uh the 6'4 anniversary so the
anniversary attainment square is june
4th and if you look at those images out
of victoria park
in hong kong downtown hong kong this has
always been the spot where since 1989
the people of hong kong particularly
young young people particularly students
would go out every single june 4th night
and hold a candlelight vigil there
in victoria park and so there's these
montage photos people put up on the
internet
where it shows that it's it's this huge
thing and it's every year
and it sort of became this sort of
hybrid
dual meaning where it's it's in
commemoration of tiananmen square but
it's also
that hey we we know you don't want us
doing this
after 1997 the handover that okay we're
part of chinese sovereignty now under
beijing but we are still going to do
this because we are hong kong and we are
free
last year it was uh incredibly
diminished crowd all of a sudden you see
this like this huge park but it's only
maybe like
uh 50 capacity and then this last year
it's empty you are going to see a lot of
people and i think you are in the united
states
moving from libertarian to authoritarian
very very quickly
with the uh nickelodeon thing where the
drag queen dancer is showing
the red salute the communist fist and
telling the kids this is a good thing
look at this and they're like flashing
on the screen
and uh just a lot of what's happening in
this country it's hyper polarization
right so
so on my main channel anything with kids
anything involving right right right
right
you're tripping you are tripping those
uh that that's a primal
red line right right but it's by
practical spiritual everything yeah the
the story of the dad and the mom in
texas fighting over custody of the kid
who was the mom said it was trans that
that said was it i mean these are
these are serious issues i covered uh
vaccine segregation on my main channel
today
because democrats are increasingly
pushing what they what is called vaccine
segregation so
there's going to be a grand reopening of
new york city where
70 of the tickets will go to people who
are vaccinated and
then 30 to people who are unvaccinated
will go to special segregated areas
uh madison square gardens do an event
where you have to be fully vaccinated so
you have to have your two full doses
it has to be a few weeks after or
whatever then you can get in
whereas red states are doing the exact
opposite so i i bring this up just uh
to tie it into what we're talking about
with china and the expansion and
possible war
china's extremely authoritarian the
authoritarian nature
is allowing them just iron fist control
of hong kong right no more protests
the u.s is being rocked and shattered by
protest
so i think what's going to happen is
you're going to see a lot of people who
are just
i mean i've already heard the
conversations where they're like well
freedom is for
peace time you know uh libertarianism
liberty is for peace time
when you're in a time of war that's when
the the rules go out the window
you've got the potential for war with
china and this is what a lot of people
are saying
because we're such a free-spirited
country that allows a lot of liberty it
allows the rise of subversive groups who
would weaken us at a time when we're
facing potential war
china's not doing that if china goes to
war their country's locked down and
everyone falls in line
if the u.s goes to war it's going to
we're going to well there's also a huge
dichotomy there as well um you talked to
uh
you know we talked about millennials
earlier right um i i don't know
how many millennial i'd love to actually
pull up the millennial home ownership
numbers we all know it's terrible we all
know what to do it's really bottomed out
but how many of how many millennial
homeowners are flying
you know american flags in front of
their houses or even interventions
right and and you know it's going to be
i don't know if there's any structures
in this but my guess is that would be
quite
quite a lot less than their parents
right in china it's the exact opposite
the the generation that you are seeing
come up now in china
are ten times more hyper nationalistic
than any that has perceived them
potentially since the communist
you know uh the communist cultural
revolution of the 1960s was there like a
noticeable change in the chinese
population after tianmin square and
because
maybe you can explain a little bit about
i mean
it would be after the the great um the
one child policies when you see the
noticeable shift it's like a plateau
just drops off i part part of me would
just
would love to see a simulation of what
these leftists would experience should
china
win the economic war and any potential
hot conflict can we send them there
yeah it's it's not it's it's but but
they wouldn't every video can just just
go right over
and for those aren't familiar it means
white left it's their word for sjw but
no no no
if the us loses this economic conflict
this trade war the economic war or even
the cold war or the hot war whatever it
becomes they're not going to live
anywhere near as good as the people of
china will live
so we can say like oh we'll send them to
china well i mean chinese cities
they have political problems there's
authoritarianism but the people still
live in city conditions
if we if we go to war and we lose that
war it's like then you live at the whims
of your
of your uh uh uh of the see what you're
saying right yeah they're gonna be
living like pows they're gonna be right
so you know you're you're you know your
ability to protest that's gone out the
window right your your
your blog your your social media
accounts your tumblrs your what
whatever it is where you're going the
reason i mentioned tumblr is because
that's you know
it's it's it's like over sharing right
it's over free it's it's
who can say the most taboo thing who can
push the most buttons that's gone
that's going overnight they're exactly
you're going to start to make people
support the ccp
they're going to have these i love it
there's a meme where these leftists are
like i'll tell you what they think about
christianity next no yeah
there's a meme where the leftists like
the bernie people are like we should put
the one percent in gulags make them
break rocks for a few months so they
know what hard work is like
it's like bro you guys don't do hard
work at all like i
i think if what they don't realize is
that the things they're advocating for
would put
them in gulags breaking rocks so they
can learn the value of hard work
they're not going to go to the guy who's
like a steve working at a steel mill
they're not going to go to the guy who's
a construction worker they're going to
keep working and they're going to be
okay they're going to go to the
intelligentsia the college academic kids
these activists
and they're going to be they're the
problem when whenever these takeovers
happen they they immediately try and
purge the intelligent intelligentsia who
made the revolution 100
yeah those people are dangerous they're
subversive right right there's a reason
that we don't talk about dementia
anymore yeah yeah everyone knows what
happens in the bench fix so but but
ultimately i bring this up because it's
like if if war is inevitable
our greatest weakness is our internal
conflict
i mean there are already people who have
been super chatting us saying things
like they think
china it's china's plan to promote this
these
anti-american ideas sure to to teach not
anti-american history lessons to claim
the country is awful
what happens then if there's completely
complete demoralization
and then a you know a chinese boat
crashes on the shores of santa monica
and a bunch of soldiers walk out
and they're like we're here to liberate
you from the oppressive racist white
people uh
paul wolfowitz right we'll be greeted as
liberators exactly well
here's the thing though when we sort of
talked about this the other day
the people who would bow to the chinese
government
aren't really the people who would have
been much of a threat had they put up a
fight anyway
and there is a gun behind everybody
that's what's the name of the chinese
army
the army no no the official name what is
it the people's
liberation army you see there there are
they've already thought of this they've
already thought this through
but if we get to the point where you
know we're all racing our embassies fly
the flags of black lives matter we're
seeing children's show fly the red
salute
the the ccp members perform the red
salute when they're you know
being brought into the party or whatever
oh yeah they're gonna come here and be
like no no
we agree with you we're the same they're
gonna be like they're going to have the
flags with the fist on it
and then the leftists are going to be
like oh this is a good thing and they're
going to say we're here to liberate you
from the evil white supremacists
and you're going to have a lot of people
being like awesome
and then the chinese communist party
will go through everything from social
media you've ever posted including all
the people that they think are on their
side look at all their
if there's one thing that got said out
of what they'll be it's not even that
it's it's not even that they'd look
they'd look at it and say who's useful
and who's not
yeah right if you're if you're of no use
to us if you
if you can't be put to work if you can't
if you're not in stem fields or
producing something of value if you're
not an actual worker
then then you're just get out of here
you're done get go
go sit and be you know go assume your
consumption bubble
sit in your pod eat your bugs right you
know that's that's you that's your job
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you